[Applause]
the ceremony that comes with being
president doesn't particularly interest
were Griego deter take the man known as
The Punisher who came to power with a
landslide victory has just one thing on
his mind we have seen our country
devastated by drugs and it does not only
affected millions but the lot of them
are no longer viable as human beings the
drug crackdown he's ordered has already
been criticized by the international
community but he has instructed the
police to press on there by placing your
life in jeopardy shoot and shoot him
dead can I be more clear and so in
places like Manila's Tondo slums police
amounting near daily operations like
this based on a similar campaign
deterred a launched during his two
decade reign as mayor of the southern
city of davao the place he earned his
ruthless reputation now he's taking it
national
[Music]
we were given rare access to join this
patrol as they hunted down the people
the new president wants to eradicate so
this is what they call a not even asked
operation they've got a list they're
going door-to-door trying to find people
they suspect drug notices or drug
pushers plays again pedicab how many
people are on the list today I don't
know more than thirty or an enthalpy
yeah this one now these new names for
people you know already known I hear
that new ones let's go let's go let's go
here we need flashlights in the cramped
darkness pick out nervous faces that was
in dinner in the bhagavata with our more
cigarette over here
whispered words become fresh leads
so I'm gonna Mimi no more than minimally
tornami paladin with Magnum and Abajo so
far half a billion surrendered and
admitted involvement in drugs these are
the kind of letters that they want the
drug users to sign effectively promises
to say they won't use again it's part of
the strategy but there are some other
aspects to this as well which are far
more controversial than just signing a
letter in the Philippines being labeled
a drug user is fast becoming a death
sentence
nationally police say they've killed
approaching 600 people in recent weeks
in this small Institute alone officers
have killed around 20 drug suspects the
start of July the level of the police is
in danger I will kill them
you have to kill them yeah yeah you
don't think twice you don't worry that
maybe they're innocent I'm worried about
the innocent about the children if you
if that the case may be but I will kill
them
[Music]
the research has six children but they
no longer have a father
last month police arrived at their door
and led her nephew's her husband away
hours later he was dead aunt Ella ganas
a school salon una y r en la parte de
personaje SE que no se Puna a second
enemy on Sabine Ilana kokkonen Lange
para popper maheno Josephine de economy
Tomas a chehon chairman Ami Loomis an
agonal pero chef Manabu
between Ivana game Vanunu Dina mengapa a
Samantha uno a saga for fara Daniel name
but it's not just police pulling the
trigger
vigilante gangs too are taking things
into their own hands bodies have been
found bound with tape their alleged
crime screwed on cardboard signs hung
around their necks
the fear is this new murderous culture
of impunity is allowing scores to be
settled under the pretense of street
justice and yet in the very slums where
most of the killings are taking place
support for the president's campaign is
very real
many feel the Menace of drugs is the
source of their problems not a symptom
but a cause and this is a necessary
measure to protect the next generation
was Boris and Tel Aviv
because I London but the rumor that
Apple but Dinah Bobby Nam somebody not
been put in my power is almost Amata
beginning I wasn't women are benign of
usual but for all the popular support an
inquiry into the spate of deaths is set
to be launched in the country Senate the
woman behind it says the appeal of the
shortcut justice reflects a deeper
problem there are misfits in all the the
structures of our government law
enforcers prosecutors and judges that's
why our justice system is broken and
that is why this shortcuts are being
encouraged in the election campaign
Rodrigo Duterte claimed bodies of
criminals would fill Manila Bay he vowed
his war on drugs would be swift and
bloody so far that much is true but at
what cost and with what consequence Tom
Rainer Sky News Manila